hello i'm your host alex freeburg and
this is the alex the analyst show thank
you so much for joining me today we are
going to be discussing the great
resignation all the way leading up to
current day where we're having a lot of
layoffs we're seeing a lot of hiring
freezes with all these companies
and i'll go into a lot of specifics a
lot of statistics on this things that i
researched and found as well as my own
personal take on it and then i'm going
to talk a little bit about what's next
what do i see happening in the short
term the long term future as well as um
you know what's going to happen with
this economy because it's been really
crazy for these past two years ever
since the pandemic started it's just
been insane there's been a lot of things
that have led up to what is currently
going on and so we're gonna kind of go
back in time to spring of 2021
we're gonna kind of reset for a little
bit
and just see the events play out uh and
how we got to where we are
and it's gonna be really interesting i'm
i'm genuinely i've been wanting to talk
about this for maybe about a month
but
um you know
other things got in the way so here we
are
so
let's go back
right because
layoffs and the downturn in the economy
they don't just happen there were a lot
of things that led up to it so let's
kind of rewind
and for all my international people out
there
i'm mostly talking about the united
states but i know for a fact that this
is happening in other countries as well
so you know what i'm talking about is
mostly for the united states but i'm
sure it's impacting you as well
so
the great resignation is is i love the
name of it first off because
um it just there's more people resigning
looking for jobs than ever before or
there were back in
mid to late 2021 and this all started
around around may
um
and
it's interesting because right around
then is when i started looking for
another job as well i started and you
guys probably saw my videos where i was
applying to places like pwc and and i
eventually got the job that i have now
so it's really interesting i was kind of
i didn't resign i didn't quit my job but
i was part of that i was part of that
looking for another job one of the most
interesting statistics i'm gonna start
off right off the bat with one of these
is that
roughly 44
of all of americans who held a job were
looking for another job that is
frankly from what i've
seen and researched online is insanely
high it usually sits like a like
20
25 44 is like double um and there were a
lot of different things that
cause that basically
so let's look into a few of these things
a few of these things that cause this
great resignation some of these things
include a toxic corporate work culture
job insecurity and reorganization
high levels of
of innovation failure to recognize
performance poor response to kova 19
better work-life balance higher pay a
long-held desire to explore a new career
path
and care for children or elderly
relatives during the pandemic there i
just threw a lot of things at you this
is the list that um i found i thought
was really accurate because a lot of
those things hit home with me which is
what i was looking for
one of the biggest things was
pay during
2021
and and especially today we were seeing
increased pay across the board
people were demanding at large companies
like amazon and other places 15 an hour
because of inflation because things were
becoming more expensive housing was
becoming more expensive so all these all
these things were getting more expensive
right and so if you're just making 10 an
hour
it's not really cutting it anymore and
so as that that baseline starts to creep
up higher and higher and higher and some
companies even going as high as like 20
dollars per hour for all of their staff
which
i think still the federal minimum for
almost all states at least in the united
states is like
seven dollars and 25 cents for a lot of
states or or eight dollars in some
states it's like crazy low so this is
like double
so
i think the biggest primary factor for
this great resignation
is pay it's money and um
we'll talk about that a little bit more
later because that is one of the main
things
one of the other biggest things this is
remote work which
it was obviously something before the
great resignation
right again i'm going to keep saying
that because i love how that um i love
that sounds the great resignation it's
just great
just fantastic um might be able to hear
my dogs in the background they're
barking at our neighbors dogs um
it's really interesting
that
before we were seeing people wanting to
because in 2020 was kind of when the the
pandemic really hit took over
everyone was just working from home
people were losing jobs and then in 2021
people felt more empowered there was
this very large
kind of
push of everyone who was basically like
we're not going back to work
all these companies are trying to get us
back into the into the
office
and people were pushing back like crazy
i mean you saw this across the board
companies like um apple were losing top
engineers uh c-level executives because
they were like if you make me go back to
that office i quit i just i will
and this wasn't just
for these people who could demand high
pay this is for everybody
that was me included i did the exact
same thing when they when my company uh
and i do not represent my company in any
way when my company said hey it's time
to go back to the office i told my boss
hey look
i get it you want me back in the office
um but i've really become accustomed and
really like this remote life and if you
try to make me go back in the office i
am going to quit
um
and my boss was really chill about that
because she had been working remote for
like 15 years so she was like i'm gonna
fight for you absolutely i get it you
know i'll see what i can do and i
eventually was able to work remote full
time they had no problem with it
but
they did want us back in the office and
they were originally we're going to be
like no you have to go in the office
and then as things progressed and people
started fighting back they really like
push back that's what a lot of companies
did
but some companies decided not to do
that they fought back and said you're
going to be in person or you're not
going to work here anymore and people
were furious
like that's what caused a lot of this
resentment towards these company
cultures that were basically saying you
need to work work in person so there
were a lot of people who left companies
entirely just because of that
so first thing is pay
things are getting more expensive the
second thing is remote work and people
companies are trying to force you back
into the office when people don't want
to go back there's a lot there's a lot
of people who do want to go back
but there's a lot of people who don't
want to go back including myself
so that was a that was a really good one
i also think that um and this was one
this is there were those nine that i
just read this is one that um
i think
i companies don't
i don't think handled the best way
is that when you're working remote i can
take care of my kids
i can take care of my parents if they
were older i have employees who are
taking care of parents who need to work
remote
and i don't think
a lot of companies really took that
super seriously
that to me was a the biggest one
especially for women shout out to all my
women out there
who are caretakers and are trying to
work at the same time
who
need to balance all of those things
i mean i'm a husband i had to balance
those things right i i had to do that as
well
honestly it's just something that
companies have not especially in the us
have not really ever done well or
handled well they just haven't they
don't they they just are like that's
your problem to deal with
uh and people were just fed up with it
they're just like look i need to do this
for the health and safety of my child so
that was another huge one that i think
was like really really um hit home
so those are some of the factors that
are starting to lead up and starting to
cause
this great resignation now let's look at
some of the statistics um
around what happened when that that
train started rolling it started right
around may of 2021.
in
all of 2021 in the u.s 48 million people
quit their jobs
and that's compared to around 33 million
in previous years as an average
so
that's
significantly higher 33 million versus
48 million just quitting their jobs
then we have um
34 oh sorry let me look at this other
one
94 of american retailers are
experiencing issues with managing job
vacancies we are having
ever almost every company was having
issues
keeping people hired keeping people in
which was um really interesting because
all these companies were having issues
with make keeping their people happy
because pay they needed to keep up with
pay and most weren't
then people were like if you made me go
back in this office i'm leaving and then
they left and they did it and they lost
thousands of people all these companies
across the board were just losing
thousands and thousands of people 48
million in 2021.
so
now they're having like back pedaling
like
higher like crazy
so
this is like
that is kind of the catalyst to get to
where we're at in current day
in
june
of 2022.
that was a huge catalyst that that piece
right there which is there's a lot of
job vacancies a lot of them
um this one's interesting uh
i saw this and i thought it was
interesting it says roughly 52 percent
of millennial and gen z workers were
likely to consider changing companies
this year which is in 2022 now and
i think that's fairly accurate that's a
pretty i mean i don't want to say it's
only gen zers and millennials but
you know a lot of people that's that's
over half of the younger workforce
wanting to change jobs due to pay or
better opportunities or what else i mean
if you're a company out there and you're
seeing this
there's a problem um
and then 41 of the global workforce in
2022 i would earlier i was talking 44 in
2021 41 and 2022 are looking to uh are
considering quitting in their jobs
high numbers just across the board
people are um
there's just a lot of uncertainty a lot
of resentment towards companies for how
they treated and how they are treating
their their employees now how people are
really gaining is kind of more of a
self-respect in a professional way and
they're like
you can't really treat me like that
anymore like there's a huge shift
towards employees being empowered to
basically say like screw you i'm doing
what i want which i'm a huge fan for i
am always i i i say the same things that
people who work on my team i'm like
i was like if they try to make you go
back in person i was like i will fight
them tooth and nail and it it's not
going to happen not on my watch not as
long as i'm here like i i just i'm like
i'm like a power to the people kind of
guy
so i i like seeing these things because
i have seen how it's been in the past
and this is just so much this is much
better uh
in certain ways
so
um
that is that is kind of what the great
resignation what what has happened it is
honestly somewhat still going on because
there's a lot of uncertainty now
the great resignation it started but at
the end of 2020
or at the end of 2021 and into 2022
we have seen
a massive amount of hiring across the
board as well as many people are
quitting they're hiring they're trying
to hire just as fast now i'm going to
stick mostly to tech industries but this
happened in my company as well like
health care and finance
finance like banking and stuff this
happened across the board but i'm going
to kind of mostly stick towards tech um
so i'm gonna i'm gonna kind of skip
ahead and then i'm gonna come back
excuse me give me one second
these are companies
that had hiring freezes and layoffs just
this month and or just last month in may
of 2022 exactly one year
after
the great resignation in may of 2021. so
exactly one year after
we're starting to see these layoffs now
here's some of the companies that are
having layoffs
meta salesforce carvana netflix
robinhood paypal microsoft uber lyft
coinbase i'm sure you've seen a lot of
these on linkedin in the news
and
a lot of people are asking what on earth
is going on what is happening i'm
applying for jobs is this going to
affect me
all great questions
and i'm going to answer those later on
because i want to go back now
to
late 2021
which is we we were seeing this huge
dynamic shift in how people conducted
business
and how people wanted to be treated and
where they wanted to work so a lot of
vacancies available and so and in these
again huge cost of living rises even
today even
on june 6 while i'm recording this
inflation is absolutely a nightmare a
cri in the it over the whole world but
in the u.s it's it's i know because i
live here it's terrible
like milk is more expensive gas is crazy
expensive housing is because becoming
extremely expensive it's always been
expensive
and
people are like i need to get paid more
so all these companies
started saying hey we can get top talent
if we just offer more
and i know for a fact that a bunch of
people are quitting meta because of
cultural issues all this metaverse stuff
they want people back in the office and
they're quitting we're gonna take that
talent we're gonna we're gonna be
charged a premium and we know that
but we're willing to do it for this top
talent because it's going to be
investment in the future
and so all these top tech companies are
just gobbling up employees as quickly as
they can
for example
coinbase at the beginning of 2021 had
1700 employees and by the time they had
layoffs this year a month ago
they had over 4 000 employees so in one
year in the span of just a little over a
year
they almost tripled their workforce
which they're a growing company they
just had a huge ipo
and and they're they're growing um
not a startup anymore but they're a very
large growing company
they need those employees but tripling
your employee count in in a year is
pretty insane
and they weren't paying a low amount
they're they're competing with other
tech top tech companies
and so
that's that's where all this really
starts to spiral
because
people
all these companies i just mentioned
meta salesforce netflix paypal uber lyft
coinbase are all hiring like crazy
they're basically
it's a free for all for who can pay the
most
for for this top talent
and this isn't just in silicon valley or
new york it is across the world really
um and in the us i saw it people every
day on my linkedin feed just i got a job
at tesla i got a job at and i test
listen on the list i'm gonna add it
really quick
um because they are
somebody i was gonna talk about a little
bit
so they start hiring like crazy that's
basically what i'm getting at and they
start hiring and they're hiring and
they're hiring and they're hiring
and then we have an economic downturn
due to a war that
honestly looking back we should have
seen coming
but something that we were hoping wasn't
gonna happen
which caused
a huge economic downturn at the
beginning of 2022
and this war
really impacted everybody across the
board
and
uh
i mean just putin screwed everybody over
from being honest he's grew his own
people over he's screwed over the entire
world i mean he's like he's like the
number one villain of the world right
now if i'm er
and that's just me being completely
like i don't know the guy
but he's he's the worst right
so
we have all these other factors and then
we have a small economic downturn the
small is relative but we have an
economic downturn and it's not great
uh it causes
inflation to rise food we're worried
about food scarcity
gasoline because russian controls a lot
of gasoline
that's a issue bread bask of the world
is compromised
and people are concerned and when people
are worried and there's fear and there's
all these things
the stocks are going to plummet and
that's what happened and companies lost
billions
i mean meta literally lost 250 billion
in one day which was the largest stock
market loss ever for any company in the
world i mean
it was
um it was insane just to read that that
250 billion dollars can be wiped out in
a day for our company
and all these companies
had to start really re-evaluating things
so like man this is an issue
and i don't think
we can sustain ourselves as things
continue
because they had been trying to sustain
themselves for the past several months
when the war started back in uh
march
february i can't remember the exact date
i didn't write down i apologize
um give me one second
i'm starting to get heated
i started like really get animated so my
mouth gets dryer quicker
so
all these factors are starting to happen
and all these companies start to realize
that
this is going to last a long time
and because of this economic downturn
consumer behaviors are changing our
stock market has changed or our stock
price has changed
we need to re-evaluate where we're
sitting and so every company all these
big tech companies are looking inward
saying
where can we cut costs
and where is the number one cost cutter
for almost every company
it's employees because that's usually
the
biggest expense for any company
and they're like well we just hired
3 000 people
and we only need 2 000.
so there you go i mean that's where
we're at and so i wouldn't say
actually let me let me finish what i'm
saying and then i'm going to
go off on a tangent for a second
or not he's not going to tangent
but companies are starting were really
forced to do this and they didn't want
to they just want to keep expanding keep
growing keep hitting all these uh
metrics that they wanted to hit
to make their stockholders happy and
keep their companies healthy and make
them look good
and when that tanked
people got scared
and so that's why all these people are
getting fired that's why all these
people are getting let go that's why
we're seeing all these hiring freezes
um
and honestly a hiring freeze is way
better than a bunch of people getting
let go but
you know
what can you do
you hired a thousand extra people you
cannot afford those thousand extra
people
given where your company is now
evaluated in this in your current stock
price and your current market uh your
current metrics for the next year based
on all the current data
and i i'm fully
i i think that following and trusting
the data that you're seeing in front of
you is a good thing and so there and so
i feel bad for saying that because a lot
of people are losing their jobs right
now
thousands every single day you see it
everywhere you're like hey i work at
tesla i just lost my job
i just have my offer rescinded i can't
uh i no longer have my job at tesla
tesla was the biggest one that i saw but
there were so many other companies i
don't know why it's always it's always
tesla right
gosh i got this itch it's always tesla
why does it have to be tesla so many
other companies were doing it but then
tesla
elon musk makes one announcement and
then it's this huge uproar all these
other companies were doing it meta was
doing it robin hood netflix they they
were having hiring freezes and offer in
rescinding offers and it was sl
perceivably slow then tesla didn't start
people started freaking out that was my
perception as well as a lot of other
people because that's all that i was
reading on the in different articles
that tesla
you know
it was tesla's fault i blame tesla as
well no i really don't
so tesla basically announced hey
we're not going to be hiring anybody
um also
we're taking back offers that we put out
uh out there coinbase did the exact same
thing coinbase was another big one
coinbase coinbase and tesla and and then
tesla also uh when i say tesla i mean
elon musk
also said
if you don't want to come back in the
office
then you can you're we're going to
assume that you quit
which is a base another basically a
sneaky way of saying
uh we need to fire a lot of people
and i think everybody and everybody saw
right through that it was not like hey i
know elon musk is not
he's very smart extremely smart
but everybody saw through that one and
he thought he was being a little bit
sneaky on that because he said if you
don't come back and work in person
because that's where people get the real
work done you come don't come back
you're fired that was basically his way
of saying um we're not doing remote work
anymore we need to
lean ourselves out a little bit to
survive this economic downturn
um but i don't want to go out and all
right fire anybody because i'm worried
about our stock price
that's how i run into it that's how a
lot of people run into
it take that for what you uh want
um
so let me read
one thing
which is
basically what i've reiterated but it's
from an actual article
and they can probably say it a little
bit more eloquently than i can it says
the news comes after tech companies
hired aggressively and completed
fiercely competed fiercely for talent in
late 2020 and 2021
as they were buoyed
by low interest rates and surging stock
prices the money has since largely
stopped flowing with the tech savvy
nasdaq composite index down 23.2 percent
this year and ventral capital capital
funding drying up so this huge system
this huge ecosystem of funneling money
and money churning and revenue and all
these processes by venture capitalists
and these companies uh creating products
and hiring people came to a halt
came to just an abrupt stop
and and that's what we're seeing play
out as we speak
and i am sure
that this is not the last company that
we're gonna see do this
it'll be more in the news of companies
having hiring freezes which is probably
the best case scenario for a lot of
these companies that that hired
aggressively like they said in in these
past years
especially last year in 2021
so
all that to say is
it was kind of a perfect storm
i mean
covid
covet itself was
terrible and and screwed over a lot
millions and millions and millions of
people as well as killed a lot of people
then the war happened
which i don't think anyone was hoping
for
and that really
tossed a wrench into this whole
conundrum that was already going on and
just made things worse just exacerbated
all the issues that we were already
having in trying to get past
and
coupled with you know
interest rates going through the roof i
mean it's just terrible just terrible
that's where we're at
so
with all of that going on
where does that leave us
what do i see in the future what have i
been reading about about how things are
going to be looking in the future
well
everything that i've been seeing as well
as my own
thoughts on the subject
is that
and i mostly agree with them because i'm
this is not my forte i'm just some
random data guy
talking about it
how i see this going is it's going to
continue
probably on a much smaller scale
hopefully
for probably another year
six months to a year at least
um going into the into the next year
they'll be
it'll be hopefully a little bit better
but
companies are going to be paying for
this for a little while
and
i hope i hope i'm not right
but
again i researched this a ton
for this video
everything that i was seeing all these
economists wall street new york times
um you know venture capitalists who are
in the industry are saying the exact
same thing they're just like you know we
have to take a step back and reevaluate
things and that takes a while it doesn't
happen overnight that takes months and
these companies don't just
restart hiring freezes after a month it
just doesn't happen it's usually several
can be several months they'll start
slowly opening it back up into certain
departments
where they need more hiring than others
so
if you're out there right now though and
here's the good take away from all this
and let me find
this right here
in the news you hear about it a lot and
it looks very scary but here's the
positive spin on all of this recent
gartner research shows that four percent
of us companies have started laying off
employees while seven percent have
frozen hiring and 15
have started slowing down hiring
and that's from gartner and and they're
pretty reputable source so
you know you see this in the news and
it's and it's scary it's it's like okay
what's happening is this gonna be more
wide scale it's only
four percent who are laying off
employees
and the four percent are mostly the huge
extremely large tech companies who
bought too much and had too much hype
around xyz
it just it is
those types of companies that's what
they do they grow at all costs and that
really really hurt them
most companies 96 of the companies
didn't do that well that's probably not
true because seven are have hiring
freezes 15 are slowing down hiring let's
just say 15 of all companies are in that
bucket right that means 85 percent of
companies are still going about business
as normal they planned accordingly
they're hiring as normal
is there a lot to worry about
um
for most people who aren't looking to
get into the tech industry at this very
moment which i know a lot are
but if you're just looking for an entry
level position at different companies
that's not going to really affect you
that much
it really isn't
it's really when you are like mid-level
senior level you're already in that tech
space where it's really going to affect
you
because
you once you are
you're in that certain price salary
bracket you're in that space of
being either with tech social media et
cetera
then it makes it a lot more difficult
because you have this huge overflux or
influx of potential
people who are trying to get hired right
and that makes a lot more difficult to
land a job so for all those employees
who are in that ecosystem for these
companies who are who are trying to get
hired it's going to be 10 times harder
to get a job
it's going to be much much much more
competitive but for the average person
for the layman like you and me
i don't think we're gonna see that big
of difference than we have seen for the
past two years which again has already
been slightly difficult
um it's been more challenging to get a
job because a lot of people are entering
the the analytics space the data space
trying to get remote work and
and the salaries are great it's very
appetizing for people to try to get in
and that's where a lot of people like
you may be you're trying to get in it's
it's already made it more difficult
right but i don't think it's gonna be
any more difficult than it is
than than it has been for the past two
years i don't think it's gonna get more
difficult for you
so that's what i got
um
just really really interesting i mean
this whole the whole world has just been
basically on fire for the past like
two and a half years
and we're all just trying to survive
myself included in in different ways
um similar and different just because of
family dynamics or job or whatever
it's been tough
so
if you've been braving that storm
like i have trying to fight for yourself
um to work remote get a better salary
get a better job
more power to you i wish you the best of
luck um the great resignation these
layoffs it's all
something we'll read about in the
history books in the future
we're living through historic times
we really are we're living through one
of
we're living through one of the
strangest economic times that
hopefully we'll see in the next
in my generation
i don't know
you never know what's gonna happen in
the future but i i can guarantee you
this is nothing like we've ever seen
before
so you know
be safe be smart uh and let's go to uh
the next part of the show which is
the sponsor for this video which is all
of you
i am super appreciative to
appreciative of the community that is
the alex the analyst channel or whatever
you want to say
you guys are honestly the best
of for everything you guys are like the
best audience i mean no other channel
really has a i feel like this is just my
personal opinion has a community like
like ours
um and so i just want to say thank you
for supporting uh the show by just
watching if you're watching all the way
through you're one of those people
so for supporting the show watching my
videos learning
commenting
all those things mean the world
and if you want to support the channel
financially you can head over to patreon
i'll have a link in the description
where you can just give me like five
bucks a month to keep doing this type of
stuff
um and it allows me to buy equipment and
lights and background stuff which i
literally bought everything you see in
the background from patreon money and so
just super appreciative you guys are
making this channel better
every month every year so
super appreciate if you want to do that
you can i really do appreciate it um
yeah that's it all right so on to
mine the very things i like to put at
the very end
um and the people who usually watch till
this long are usually like my core
people my like my main
fans i don't like the word fans but my
main like community
um
which is we have our question of the
week and then our vegetable of the week
which i say vegetable the week but
it's been like two months since i've
done my last
episode of this
so
yeah it's like vegetable of two months
but our question of the week comes from
latina valencia
valencia
i can't i can't pronounce her name but
she has been commenting a ton on this
channel she's been going like binge of
this channel so she might be watching
this right now because i've seen like 20
other of her comments
and questions but she says what if i
have the skills but no degree can i
still get a job
i i've answered similar questions to
this in the past um
but
you know we're in a really strange space
the degree is not necessary but a degree
does help
so
um when i when i talk to people like
this or i mentor people who are in this
exact position they have all the skills
they know what they know
but they don't have a degree they don't
even they don't have an associates they
probably just have a high school diploma
but they may not have a bachelor's a
master's a phd
so let's say she only has a high school
degree
which is what i'm guessing is what she's
asking if we only have a high school
degree we don't have an upper a higher
education from that can i get a job the
answer is yes i've worked with several
people who have gotten a job it is just
more difficult and marketing yourself
and making connections is actually far
more important
than it not far more important it's just
it's more important for you
because you do not have a bachelor's
degree to kind of boost yourself
when you have a bachelor's degree you
automatically meet a minimum requirement
for a lot of jobs
so
if you don't what you need to do is
really be really good at marketing which
is creating a personal brand
making your presence known on linkedin
creating a website creating a youtube
channel
it can help you land jobs
i
i am not trying to brag at this moment
this is for educational purposes only
in the past month i have received two
unsolicited job offers
now that's at like the managerial level
but if you create a personal brand at
your level at the data analyst level
entry level
analyst level
and you create a personal brand people
will seek you out
that doesn't happen overnight but i've
seen people do it in six months
where they create this personal brand
they make themselves known and people
start reaching out to them because
they're like hey i really like your
content i really like what you're
posting on medium or like what you're
posting on linkedin it doesn't have to
be a youtube channel
but people will reach out to you
that is a hundred percent a fact and is
happening more and more and i see more
people creating channels like mine for
that exact reason it's for marketing
it's for creating a personal brand where
you can say hey this is what i've done
this is what i know
and when people learn from that they can
recommend you for positions they can
um if they're hiring they're like wait i
like this person i like their
personality i like the the content that
they're putting out it's very close to
what we need let me reach out to this
person
i i say all that to say
is i have seen it firsthand and i'm
seeing it for people from much smaller
channels just like a few thousand
subscribers and they're posting
consistently
and they're posting on the similar type
of content they are getting reached out
to and it's just fascinating it's a
totally different um ecosystem so it's a
if you really want to put yourself out
there
that is a great way to do it um but
youtube can be a little bit more
difficult than something like linkedin
i think linkedin is a little bit easier
because you're just posting
you're posting text it's a little bit
easier
so all to say it's absolutely possible
it it just comes down to who you are how
hard you fight for it um
a little bit of luck
15 20 luck
so yeah absolutely possible
to answer your question in a very long
way
and pat myself on the back a little bit
there yeah y'all knew i threw that in
there for me
i lied that was 100 just to struck my
ego
um
now we are at my favorite part of the
entire video if i'm being completely
frank it's the vegetable of the week i
have covered
so many vegetables so many vegetables i
think most people know about um bok choy
might be the only one that some people
have not heard of
i've covered almost everything though
this is a really interesting one because
i think it's really polarizing vegetable
slash most people don't i don't know if
you know if they know it's a vegetable
the
the vegetable of the week is horseradish
if you don't know what horseradish is
look it up cause it's a it's a
really in i mean you've probably all
heard of horseradish i don't i i just
don't think most people know it's even a
vegetable it's like it's like a product
um
because that was me uh a couple years
ago anyways um horseradish is it's it's
this
very bitter tasting horseradish sauce is
what i'm referring to this is very
bitter tasting uh
i can't even explain it
but it's a sauce and it goes on
different meats and different stuff i
personally
like it
uh i don't think most people do though
that's just my opinion
but
try for yourself
see what you think
be different than the rest try it before
you judge it
ah it might just be your favorite
vegetable unknowingly your favorite
vegetable ever but it's like i think
it's like fermented i'm googling this
we're at the end of the video i mean you
don't have to stay i'm just googling
things down
googling what is horseradish
what is
is horse
radish
i'm googling this to be more specific
because i'm sure a lot of people are um
okay
all right i'm bringing you over here
horseradish is a perennial plant of the
family family
rasekia it's a root vegetable cultivated
and used worldwide as a spice and as a
condiment
that gave me
no information
same family as mustard and wasabi that
explains it man muslim wasabi like
really strong like
hits you in the mouth uh kind of flavors
um it's a cousin of broccoli cauliflower
and brussels sprouts all previous
vegetables of the weeks i will say
anyways that gave you that gave me no
information i actually know less than i
did before but there's you know it's
horseradish sauce
you should try it out
um
yeah that's the end of the video
um
i've been making it i've been making it
a thing where at the end i just keep
talking i don't have anything planned i
promise you my notes are done
um
that is the horseradish is the last word
in my notes and now i'm talking to you
and
what that means to me
is it means that i have someone out
there listening
who
is connecting with me
on a deeper level than everyone else
because everyone else who is not here in
this moment who is not hearing this
hopefully asmr-like
voice speaking to them they're not
hearing this experience i'm going to get
closer to the mic
they're not hearing and feeling this
experience i'm looking at myself to make
sure i look as creepy as possible
they don't understand
what we
as a collective as a one as a unit
understand
which is
this is where we really connect
you and i
i'm talking to you
uh so i really appreciate you listening
there the i would actually probably say
the most the people listening to this at
this moment are people who forgot or or
can't cancel out right now they're like
driving or at work or something and they
can't flip to the tab
or open their phone where to exit out
and so they're now they're just like
what is this guy talking about uh
so i get it i'm sorry
i forgot totally forgot to say and this
is not a connecting thing
i gave away like 20 of these mugs um
a couple weeks ago
and the people sent me video or
uh they post like pictures online on
like linkedin anything it was probably
one of the happiest moments
of the
merch
my merch
journey which is very small i don't push
it at all because
that's not what i do
but it you know it just it people like
having this besides me and like smiling
with it and like
really enjoying it made me um
extremely happy
i plan on doing a lot more giveaways uh
this next year
because
i just i just want people to have it
i don't care if they pay for it or not
i'm just gonna give it away
i really don't but i do appreciate the
people who do who do purchase it
what's been going on in my life um if
you don't follow me i should have given
my self a shout out for this if you
don't follow me on instagram or twitter
i've been really active on those
instagram i was gonna say specifically
because um today
my son
he's three years old
he's
almost three and a half years old
and he went to his first camp today
at my my dad's school my dad's a head
master of a school
um and they had a summer camp and it
went down to three years old and we put
them in there
and
it was just i was tearing up all morning
i'm tearing i'm not just thinking about
it was the cutest thing i've ever seen
in my entire life
and he was just so excited he just
wanted to be a big kid like his big
sister he was just so excited to
go to school and go to camp and see
grandpa
that is those are the moments that i
live for
those are the moments that i will never
ever forget like i just i won't um
and i didn't get to drop him off but i
got to hug him and say goodbye to him
and he was just like i'm gonna make
friends i'm going to be a good boy and
it just i i was like tearing up
it was it was
so pure and innocent and
childlike
i just wish the world was more like that
i i wish the world was more
like my three-year-old son getting it to
go to get getting to go to camp
um we just live in a much better world
um
and and so i got to pick him up from the
camp
and when i picked him up the teacher was
like he did amazing he did so good he's
such a good kid
and my son like ran up to me and gave me
a hug and he had his little nap mat and
his backpack which is just adorable and
he's like i had the best time i can't
can i come back tomorrow i'm telling you
like guys i don't
i i
i don't cry a lot i don't get very
emotional but that made me emotional i
was like my goodness i just i wish they
would stay like this forever i do when i
don't
that's a little a little tidbit of
into insight into my life right now i'm
just an emotional wreck
because literally
12 hours ago i was dropping him off at
at this camp uh
he's just the cutest kid i've ever seen
in my life and i still have one um
that's gonna be going through that
because she's two
um she'll be going through that next
year
so
yeah
just um parent stuff if you don't have
kids um you know you may not i'm sure
you may have cousins or nephews or
nieces or something
where
you know you can understand that it's
just it's just pure
unfiltered joy
um it is very rare in this world and i
hope that everyone can experience
something like that in their life
that is and i mentioned this um in a
linkedin post and a twitter post
not on instagram
different content for each platform
that's why you got to follow me on all
of them
but i mentioned i was just like you know
money the more money i make
the more money i make the less i care
about it it's just that paradox of you
fight so hard to make money and then
once you have it it's just like not
important and it's 100 happen to me
i i i now make a very good salary
um and
it pays for everything that i need
and it has become
i would i would get rid of it in an
instant
if it meant putting my family first
i i mean that wholeheartedly and i've
talked to my wife about this i was like
listen if if my work ever be
somehow became more important than my
family i was like you tell me i will
quit
i say that in a moment maybe it's a
different scenario in the future but
in my heart of hearts i know that that
is a fact i just family has been so
incredibly important to me um
in the past
i mean ever since i got married of
course but this past year when i moved
closer to my family in south carolina
they've just it's just become
that much more
important
um
and so i don't know where you are in
your journey you may be where i'm at
where it's like money is not what it
used to mean
now i look at money as money is great i
need it i have to have it
but it is definitely
not something that i'm actively like
chasing anymore um it wasn't like an
idol i wasn't like
more money the better person i am it was
just like i want to really provide for
my family make it make them happy give
them everything they need and i've done
that and now i look at money as like
you know it's a it's a byproduct of me
working that's great i'm glad to have it
but
anything happens to my family
my work is bottom of the barrel
i will take off a month of work and if
you want to fire me great if i had a
medical emergency my wife was in the
hospital i will straight up quit or i
will straight up not show up to work if
you want to fire me great
that is just i
this is not not as high priority um and
priorities change as you get older
and when you're young i say young i'm
still pretty young but when you're young
and you're chasing after the dream which
has been me
um
you know that is like one of the driving
factors and now that's not my driving
factor anyways you've heard way too much
about my family way too much about um
yeah you've heard way too much about my
family it's all i've been talking about
i just been in my feels today guys
i just been all up in my fields today uh
so i hope i hope this isn't like the
most
sad ending to
an episode ever
but
i just need somebody to vent to i talk
to my wife about this stuff but i need
another outlet
to vent about my emotions and my
feelings right
um if not you who
you guys you guys are my my community
so um
yeah i hope you i hope that's okay i'm
sure um
some people will listen to the end
but you know
that's all i got that's all that's been
happening that's been the biggest thing
and it just happened today the biggest
thing that's happened in a while and
it's just i don't know it makes you
re-evaluate like your whole life
it's just a different level of happiness
having kids for me for me personally
it's been a different level of happiness
and joy
and
like pureness from children it's been
also the most challenging thing ever oh
my gosh my kids are so difficult um
sometimes um
it's just so challenging but then they
have these moments where it just makes
all of that disappear makes it all worth
it now again i'm rambling about my kids
and my family a lot to say is
i love my family they are they're the
most important thing to me
in on this on this material earth
yeah so uh i guess i'll wrap it up uh i
appreciate you i do care about you
you know message me on
twitter
linkedin hit me up ask me questions
tell me your emotional story so i can
connect with you on a deeper level
i hope that my asmr bit was not weird
i don't watch asmr so i don't know if
that's a weird thing to do i just know
what it is
i hope it was not
i hope it wasn't weird
that's all i have to say all right guys
uh i'm signing off because again
it's getting weird uh but thank you
again for your time for watching that
was i hope this was interesting i found
it very fascinating when i was doing my
research is absolutely fascinating how
things have been going the past like two
years
just insane absolutely insane all right
guys i'm headed out i will see you
in the next video
goodbye